the biggest mistake people make in
Fitness advice is realizing that they
are not their client your client doesn't
want to eat chicken or broccoli your
client doesn't want a six-pack they've
told you they want a six pack cuz
they're telling you what they think they
want you to hear my clients will come to
me go I want a sixpack I'm like no you
don't tell me what you want okay cool so
you want to fit in the dress that you
fit in 3 years ago that's very different
to a sixpack especially for a woman guys
are like I want big pecs and I'm like
send me a picture of yourself topless
and I'm like whoa Let's Lose £30 let's
get you running a 5k without killing
yourself then let's talk about PEC some
people do want to look like bodybuilders
but the majority of my clients don't and
I don't offer extreme deficit I don't
offer fasted cardio I don't offer
getting people ready for show because in
every sport on the day you compete you
should be physiologically and
psychologically your best however when
it's down to bodybuilding and physique
the day you compete you're
physiologically and psychologically your
worst why are we epitomizing that as
Fitness but it's clearly not Fitness